[Musik]
diese schreckliche meldung die zeigt was
sich da gerade für ein neues
flüchtlingsdrama mitten in europa auch
bei uns abspielt bei görlitz ganz im
osten deutschlands an der grenze nach
polen da ist die polizei heute früh auf
eine gruppe von flüchtlingen auf einem
acker getroffen 30 flüchtlinge und einer
von ihnen mittendrin tot hier sehen wir
das aktuelle bild von dort aus der nähe
von görlitz das uns erreicht hat also
eine gruppe von flüchtlingen steht da
herum um eine leiche dieses bild müssen
wir einmal erklären ein ort und was ist
da passiert das machen wir mit unserer
bild chefreporter hans jörg vehlewald
was hast du für informationen dort aus
görlitz was ist das für ein neues
flüchtlingsdrama dort also es geht um
eine gruppe die heute morgen ungefähr 7
uhr einem passanten aufgefallen dass der
herd sich bei der polizei gemeldet die
haben sofort sind hingefahren dieser
gruppe ist offenkundig sind flüchtlinge
die mit einem renault transporter aus
polen angekommen sind direkt erste
ausfahrt raus auf einen acker haben dann
so hat es die polizei ebenfalls
vorgefunden um eine person
herumgestanden noch neben dem
transporter und diese person war tot
inzwischen wissen wir ist es ein 32
jähriger iraker ob die anderen auch alle
aus dem irak stammen oder afghanistan
oder anderen ländern ist nicht klar man
hat dann versucht die polizei hat
versucht mit sanitätern zu reanimieren
das hat nicht funktioniert
dann kamen die die
mordkommission hat das untersucht hat
auch mit einem in der nähe stehenden
fahrer gesprochen denn ein
begleitfahrzeug offenkundig unterwegs
war b klasse mercedes dieser fahrer ein
48 jähriger türke und der hat dann
beschrieben dass der fahrer dieses
renaissance des flüchtlings wagens auch
ein türke ein 42-jähriger sei man nach
dem wird im moment noch gesucht mit
hubschrauber mit hundestaffeln in der
gegend er ist offensichtlich ganz
einfach getürmt und man sieht ja auch
wenn man sich die strecke anguckt wir
gehen alle davon aus die polizei geht
davon aus dass diese dieter
flüchtlingstreck in belarus ausbilder
russ kommt über die übliche strecke
sozusagen belarus von minsk vom
flughafen an die grenze nach polen dann
nach polen hinein und dann dann von
schleppern übernommen die schlepper die
dort verfügbar sind und sich auch teuer
bezahlen das mit einigen tausend euro
die klauen oder mieten in der regel dort
in ostpolen fahrzeuge an davon ich gehe
auch davon aus dass dieses dieser
renault transporter auch dort von dort
stammte wald dann fallen sie dort vor
ort nicht auf denn dort an der grenze
wird sehr scharf kontrolliert und sie
haben es offensichtlich geschafft dann
quer durch polen einmal über warschau
lodz breslau bis gerade mal so hinter
die grenze hinter die deutsch polnische
grenze zu kommen und dass das jetzt
einer dabei gestorben ist ist war
eigentlich eine frage der zeit
selbst ein bild vor ort gemacht dass
selbst auch eine grenze gereist welche
bilder bewegen sich da besonders was
konntest du das beobachten für mich mir
geht das wirklich zu herzen und ich
jetzt sehe die haben all das was dort an
der grenze zwischen polen und belarus
passiert die haben das überlebt diese
haben sind durchgekommen und
offensichtlich ist einer hat es einer
dann am ende doch nicht geschafft die
haben schon eine riesen tortur hinter
sich die flüchtlinge dort an der
weißrussischen polnischen grenze
durchkommen die werden in der regel hin
und her geschoben die belarussen lassen
sie durch nach polen auf polnischer
seite werden sie aufgegriffen verstecken
sich aber zunächst einmal lange im wald
bei minus temperaturen im wald meistens
vollkommen durchnässt durch regen
dadurch auch dass sie durch flüsse
warten müssen oder ganz einfach dort im
sumpf das ist sumpfgebiet er sich einen
einsinken gerettet werden wenn sich dann
irgendwann geschafft haben zu einem
solchen transporter von zu schleppen
hatte die organisierten schleppern dann
hätten sie eigentlich schon drei kreuze
machen können wären eigentlich sicher
gewesen dass wird dieser sicherlich auch
gedacht haben ich weiß nicht was diese
gruppe schon alles hinter sich hat er
hat auf dem weg ist noch lang an bild
chefreporter hansjörg fehler weil bei
uns bei bild live im studio ein neues
flüchtlingsdrama dass sich gerade
abspielt an der grenze nach b la rosa an
der grenze nach polen aber eben auch
mitten in deutschland mittlerweile in
diesem fall direkt in der nähe von
görlitz heute früh ein toter
flüchtlingen dort in einer gruppe von
ungefähr 30 flüchtlinge offenbar das
ergebnis davon dass sie zuvor zusammen
gefragt waren dort auf einem renault
transporter und einer von ihnen musste
eben dort auf dem acker bei görlitz sein
leben lassen 1 ja
das ist einfach dramatisch sind man muss
sich vorstellen so ein renault
transporter der hat nicht viel platz da
sind keine sitzplätze sind 30 leute ein
gefecht und diesen kleinen fahrzeug
möglicherweise hat er auch ganz einfach
keine luft mehr bekommen oder auch durch
den stress die anderen flüchtlinge sind
jetzt zurück an die grenze gebracht
worden dort gibt es ein flüchtlingsheim
wo sie untergebracht werden wenn jetzt
erstmal auch crooner untersucht werden
aber vor allem auch versorgt das foto ja
noch einmal ganz kurz zeigen dort von
dem acker in der nähe von görlitz hat
haben wir haben wir nicht vorliegender
wir sehen hinter uns noch mal aus der
ferne diesen acker also dort heute das
sind bilder von dort aus der nähe von
görlitz die uns alle auf schrecken die
aber vor allen dingen die regierung auf
strecken muss und alle die die im moment
noch wegschauen bei diesem neuen
flüchtlingsdrama dass sich eben hier
mitten in europa und mittlerweile auch
bei uns in deutschland abspielt hat es
vor allem an eine sache die werden jetzt
im in ein heim gebracht wo sie versorgt
werden können auf der polnischen
polnischen grenzsoldaten während sie
nach dem was ich dort erfahren habe ganz
einfach wieder zurückgeschickt wurden
direkt über die grenze direkt in die
arme der belarussischen grenzsoldaten
diese wieder zurückgeschickt hätten im
pingpong spiel das ist ich bin heilfroh
in einem land zu leben in dem so mit
flüchtlingen umgegangen wird und danach
geguckt wird wie man sie möglicherweise
in die heimat in richtung heimat wieder
zurückschicken kann aber erstmal
versorgen ein unmenschliches drama dass
ich jetzt gerade abspielt und das ein
erstes todesopfer gefordert hat hans
jörg vehlewald vielen herzlichen dank
für deinen besuch im studio